Awesome, now if we can just quickly get our names so Ricky, Ricky over there, Mazin, Alvean,
and then Hugo, Paxton, Caillou, okay so question one, what were your first impressions of the
game?
Yeah.
It wasn't very pretty.
It wasn't very pretty?
It didn't like colours.
Sorry.
Okay, that's fair.
It's completely valid feedback.
Alright, so the colours in question, what did you like about them?
Just a bit swampy.
Swampy?
A bit dark.
Okay.
Alright.
I didn't notice the colours as much, I did think that the opening home page, there was
quite a lot going on.
So overcrowded?
Yeah, more so that like there was a lot going on there so that limited the size that everything
could be to try and fit it onto the screen, so I feel like it could have benefited from
maybe prioritising some things, making a few things a little bit bigger, just so it was
kind of more obvious what was there rather than trying to just put all of it on there
kind of limited the way that the things could breathe and be a little bit more isolated.
I probably would have focused on like one, either like your past expenses or like paying
new expenses instead of having them both on that screen.
There's not too much going on.
I did actually, I had a moment of confusion as to what pay up was, I was looking at it
thinking, am I paying there, who's paying here, is this shit that needs to be paid soon
or is this actually I can pay it right here?
Okay, that's good.
Alright.
Did you find that the colour settings were any use of changing how you felt about the
whole swampy feel?
Oh, that was just like accessibility stuff, so yeah, that was fine, that was good, I got
my problems there.
Did you like the alternatives colour scheme more or?
What was it?
The dark mode version?
Yeah, yeah, that was good.
I think the dark mode worked better with the greens and like blues that were on there.
You felt the dark mode looked better with the greens and blues?
I do like a dark mode though, so I might be biased, but yeah, I did like the other alternatives.
Alright, sweet.
Thank you very much.
We'll move on to the next question, assuming no one has any other first impressions of
the app that they want to share?
No.
Awesome.
Second question.
Shoot, I'm pulling on the wrong questions, where did we actually put the actual, I'm
going to pause this for a second.
Yeah, awesome, thank you very much, good for catching that.
As I was saying, the next question is, describe your experience as you navigated the app,
so we're sort of taking a focus on navigation here, how you felt while you were going through,
that kind of thing.
Take a moment to think.
I don't know, I was a bit, it's pretty easy to get through the task, to be honest.
Pretty easy?
I'm just going to beg for forgiveness on Figma being Figma, so just try and take it
on how the design actually should have looked.
I thought the navigation was good with it, I liked the separation that you had into your
tabs at the bottom, I thought that was good.
I thought the way that you implemented the swiping functionality was really cool.
I thought that the splitting you did between the stuff that was in your three bar menu
and the stuff that was found elsewhere along the bottom and on the home screen, I thought
that was intuitive.
When asked to do a task that was like, oh, go into the settings or whatever, I was like,
okay, there's not a settings tab at the bottom, it'll be in the three bar menu.
Yeah, and it was there.
Agreed.
I didn't really realise that swiping even existed.
Oh, could you swipe across?
Yeah.
Oh no, that was sick.
There was one where you could swipe down and the scrolling was good as well.
Something came up and you could swipe it away, I thought that was weird.
I thought the insights tab had a bit of an ambiguous name, it would have been better
to be like analysis or I don't know.
So did that give you any confusion when you were going through?
Well, I didn't really know that it was going to be charts and stuff.
I suppose the icon does say, or does show a chart, but you know, it almost would have
been better to have the insights on the home page instead of so much detail.
Maybe, I don't know.
What was the question again?
The question is about navigation, how did you feel about your experiences while navigating
it?
So the fact that you didn't notice there was swiping is a valid part of the navigation
thing, that is a valid thing to bring up.
Any other comments on navigation?
Navigation is pretty smooth.
I like it.
But just a little confusion on the pay up thing and on the insights being.
I didn't actually ever use the icon that's at the bottom that's for the pay one.
I never used it, I used the pay button that was on the home screen.
You pressed the pay button that was on the home screen rather than the one at the bottom.
I noticed it later when I was going to insights, I was like, does it actually do the same thing?
I wasn't sure.
We'll go on to the next question then.
The next question which is, were there any parts of the app that you found confusing
or hard to use?
Yeah, it was that.
I mean it wasn't confusing but pay up on the front then pay up down the bottom.
Upcoming payments and pay up are two separate things as well.
So upcoming payments and then pay up right below, you felt that was a bit confusing between
those two?
Upcoming payment, why?
Do you need me to slow down?
No.
Is the upcoming payments, are they interactable there or is that purely informative?
Like in your idea for the...
They should be.
Click on the bottom.
Let's just try the arrow.
It'll do something.
The arrow, yes, the arrow will make it expand.
I don't think the individual groceries or like the individual things are.
So you think it would have made sense for the...
When you're showing something that's in like upcoming payments, in my head I go, okay,
that's upcoming, I should deal with it right now.
I should click on it and then pay from it from there.
Rather than having to go to a different area and then click that.
So you think that the upcoming payments, each payment should be clickable and should take
you to that payment?
Yeah, I feel like that would be, and it would even consolidate potentially some of the...
I think it's supposed to work that way.
I don't know if that's just Figma, I can't remember.
It could just be that it wasn't implemented.
Even if it is meant to be done that way, it would have been good to have like some dots
or like a pencil or anything.
A pencil, something that indicates edit or click on it?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah.
All right.
So you think that the editing stuff should...
For the payout, you wouldn't click on it, right?
Like that doesn't...
Doesn't seem to allow clicking right now.
Whether that's supposed to happen or not, I can't remember.
But I'm supposed to go to pay when you do that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So anything else then?
Any other thoughts that you felt were confusing on how to use?
There was one part for me within the three bar menu.
The three bar menu?
Let's bring that up real quick.
Yeah.
There was the help and support tab there.
But then there was also help and support within the app settings.
And my first reaction was to click that, which wasn't implemented.
And then I was like, oh, app settings, help and support.
So it felt like there was potentially two areas
where the help and support was going to be
that weren't going to lead to each other.
Makes sense.
So you felt it was confusing to have a help and support section
in the hamburger menu and also any side of the app settings.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
That's great feedback.
Anyone else?
Any other aspects that you felt were confusing or hard to use?
When I was doing it over there and I had to get the display settings up.
Remember I didn't know which one to click?
Yeah, that's a good point.
You went with how you weren't sure between household and app settings, yeah?
So I just went to app settings.
What would you say we could do better on that front?
What are these even in household settings?
Oh, is that like the flat household?
Oh, okay.
So something that would have made it clear that the household was in a flat.
Yeah, like manage household.
Management or something.
Okay.
Because I don't know what you want to have with your app,
but to me managing what would be in a tab like that
is like managing the members that are in the household
or like the flat payments that you're having in there.
To me that's less of a setting and more of like a thing.
So settings perhaps is what kind of...
Yeah, settings to me is like app functionality,
which I don't quite think is up there.
Awesome.
All right, anything else?
Any other aspects you felt were confusing or hard to use?
Nothing.
Sweet.
Let's move on to the next question.
How did you feel about the color scheme of the app?
It's a swampy answer.
We've had one person talk about the swampy answer.
Anyone have anything else?
We can bring up sort of the color scheme across different pages here.
I don't mind the greens.
We'll just wait for the latte.
So you don't like the greens?
No, I don't mind the greens.
You don't mind the greens?
I don't mind like the way that you have the toning of the greens.
They've got the lighter one, and then they've got the even lighter one,
and then they've got the darker one.
I think the color theory stuff that they've done is good.
Okay.
They could have chosen some other colors.
But I don't dislike this color.
I would use it still.
But I acknowledge that there could be a better one.
Okay, what other colors would you say are better than swampy green?
I reckon it could have been better, but it's making all the icons white.
What's that?
Making all the icons and text on the dark green and white.
Making the icons on the dark green and white.
So right now we're seeing obviously that Payup and the hamburger
and the bottom bar are all in black.
Or blue if that's the kind of selected one.
But you're saying those should be white to better contrast the dark green background?
Yeah.
Okay.
There is also on the homepage, there's the pay button that's on the green.
To me, I don't like the way that the blue interacts with the green there.
I don't like how the blue pay button is on the light green.
That could just be...
Feels too much of a contrast maybe?
I think that blue is just a little bit darker.
Too dark?
Too dark.
Because you've got a nice pastel kind of lightish green.
And you have like a navy heavy blue.
And you've got the darker green for your header and footer.
And then the navy is even darker.
Which to me suggests that it's like...
The things that are in between the header and footer to me
should be lighter than the header and footer.
Gotcha.
Kind of like the borders.
That's very good feedback.
All right.
And then while we're on that subject, we may as well talk about the dark mode equivalent.
So let's jump over to app settings.
Let's go to display settings.
And let's switch it over to dark mode.
So with that in mind, what are you guys thinking for the dark mode settings?
How does that look to you guys?
Thoughts on the color scheme in dark mode?
See, I never went to here.
I never went back.
I can't lie.
That one I think someone might have messed up with using the right variables.
Yeah, it is just a little bit dark.
I don't mind the black background.
And I think it works kind of nicely with the lighter green for the header and footer.
I like that the text is now white and the icons are now white as well.
Yeah.
With the dark mode, this should be like contrast.
Like a lot of contrast.
Yeah, I think it's just the colors for the bubbles and where it says broadband and stuff.
I can't see that it's separated.
I can't differentiate that that's on a different layer than the background.
Yeah.
You can't differentiate that that's on a different layer than this background.
Like the color that is here is very similar to the black that's in the background where
it's kind of hard from the distance that I'm at of not even quite a meter, I can't tell
it apart.
Okay.
All right.
I'm just going to other pages sort of thing.
Yeah.
I think.
Yes, no.
I mean, at least you've got the important information.
The blue button is a bit too much.
It's a little bit.
It definitely pops out as like an interactable button.
Yeah.
But it doesn't look nice with the...
It doesn't quite work with it.
Okay.
So in the payoff, the blue button, the pay buttons for each of these kind of stand out
too much.
They're like a little bit of an eyesore.
Yeah.
It feels a bit disjointed from the other color scheme.
Okay.
And then expenses.
Yeah.
This is also just like...
Oh.
Someone didn't use the right variables, I think.
So in the expenses future section, someone obviously might have made a mistake there.
But all right.
Trumpage.
So yeah.
You can't read those.
It's the dark text on the dark background as well.
The dark text on the dark background?
The text is white.
I could read it.
So on the home page in dark mode, the upcoming payments.
Yeah.
The dark text on the green.
Like the fact that the actual number for $100.
I can read that.
Perfect.
Yeah.
And I can read upcoming payments.
I just can't read what's below it.
Makes sense.
Because it's black on really dark color.
Is it an accident or is it...
I'm pretty sure it's an accident.
Yeah.
But awesome.
All right.
We'll jump over to app settings.
See, actually this looks good.
This probably looks good.
You like how the app settings look like in dark mode?
It looks great in dark mode.
Yeah.
I do like that.
And then in light mode, do you think it looks all right?
Yeah.
It looks fine to me.
It looks fine in dark mode.
All right.
Sweet.
We'll move on to the next and final question.
If this were a real app, would you use it?
Why or why not?
No.
Probably not.
Nah, dude.
Sorry.
I mean, when you guys come to us, you cannot fucking slay us.
Honestly, we want it.
No.
Listen.
We want you to listen.
Going to the home page?
Dark or light mode?
Light mode.
I think if I was using an app, I would want more visual representation.
You have your Insights tab, which has the pie chart and the graphs and stuff.
I'd want more of a focus on that kind of summative kind of visual.
So you want more insights?
Even if it was more visual, more graphs?
Yeah.
Something that I can see quickly and be like, oh, okay.
Here's my summary.
Here's my thing.
How about bar graphs?
Bar graph?
I thought it was kind of funny with the rent that there was a bar graph because it's just
the same value the whole time.
That's fair.
I think that bar graphs, in terms of weekly representations, I think that's good.
I think food is a better example, I think.
Yeah.
I like that because it's a good way of tracking your history.
If there was some summative feature on the homepage or something.
On the homepage.
Something that I open your app, I see it immediately.
I don't need to go to the Insights tab.
Some sort of indicator.
The same way we have a preview of expenses and a preview of payouts.
The homepage, to me, should have a summary of the app.
It should have, here are your most pressing payments, which you have with the upcoming payments.
Here's what you need to pay.
And then here's a little summary of where you're at monetarily.
So what would you want on the homepage in terms of the insights?
What kind of insight would you want immediately in your face?
Just kind of like the pie chart you have is good.
Here's your little piece.
We cleaned total expenses.
I know, but we created something that I like.
The point to make is that you can use a calendar to just remind yourself when you need to pay bills.
So the app has to have some sort of functionality beyond that.
And if you want to manage your expenses, you want to see all of the money.
Where it's going.
What is being spent on.
So when you say all of the money, are you referring to all of the money or all of the money related to the flat stuff?
All of the flat stuff.
How much is being paid to wear each week.
Right. We're kind of getting a bit messy now.
We're questioning the value of the entire app.
That's fair. That's the point of the question.
So you wouldn't use this to manage flat expenses with other people?
Probably not, dude.
I can remember rent stealing on a Tuesday every week.
And I do it now with my own flat.
But if someone pays for, I don't know, say toiletries or something and they say,
Oh yeah, chuck me like $20 for this.
You don't want that to be sort of built into the app?
Or have an app for it?
I mean, yeah, but...
Or do you reckon that's just not worth it?
You're just like, yeah, sure, they said $20, I'll give them $20, done.
Well, I guess the point of that is to cater for that, right?
I mean, in my current flat, I'm not doing that.
If someone buys toiletries, they say, send me $20, and I do it.
But the point of this app is to incorporate that, right?
So the idea behind the pay-ups.
We're somewhat in the market for an app of this type.
Yeah, but go back to the main page.
The home page?
Yeah, the home page.
There's total owing, upcoming payments.
It doesn't say who's paid, or it doesn't pay up.
In pay-up, we do see the people who have paid certain expenses.
Are those the people that have already paid?
I thought those were the things you had to pay.
Well, the idea is someone has paid for it, and you have to pay them for it.
Pay them back for it.
Like, say, for example, Alex has paid for rent, and butter, and power.
And so now your job is to pay your share of that.
So I'd go over here, and I'd say, yep.
I'd go to here, and I'd say, I want to pay $80.25 for his power.
And I pay for that.
Or say that I paid for that.
Those are bills that Alex has put up.
Those are bills that Alex has paid for already.
That you need to pay your share for.
It's like if Alex goes and pays the rent, it's like, all right, cool.
I just paid $2,000 in rent.
You guys can each chuck me $500.
To be honest, I'd almost just scrap paying on the home screen.
I'd just make it so you could only pay here.
So you would not want to see things you need to pay still?
No, I'd want to see things.
Isn't that up?
Isn't that in the upcoming payments?
Aren't they almost the same thing?
You're saying that upcoming payments and pay up are almost the same thing?
I don't know.
What's the difference?
Wouldn't you like to see what you need to pay?
Sorry, let me rephrase.
Upcoming payments is meant to represent expenses that nobody has paid yet.
Things that will need to be paid.
Whereas pay up is meant to be, you know, a flatmate has already paid for this.
Now you need to pay them your share.
Okay.
So the upcoming payments are assigned, are they?
The upcoming payments are sort of more like recurring things that need to happen over time.
It's dated to the whole flat, right?
Everyone on the flat needs to pay groceries.
And then if you go down into pay up, Alex has already paid rent.
And you need to pay Alex back for what they paid for your section.
Although in this case, that would be like rent for next month.
Whereas that would be rent like for last month or whatever.
And you still have to pay him for last month.
But the idea is that rent is coming up again and someone needs to pay for that.
Yep.
But you felt like that wasn't intuitive?
I feel like this whole sort of conversation has proven that.
That's fair.
If it's not intuitive enough, that's a glaring flaw.
It's hard to, because with the above section, the upcoming payments.
I feel like that might make more sense if it was stuff that was specific to the user, the current user.
Because that seems like groceries is that $30 in total for the flat.
Who's the person that's going to pay that?
Do you then need to like talk outside of the app and be like, okay, I'll pay that and then you pay me back in the app.
Makes sense.
Whereas like you could potentially add in an expense and then assign that to one of the flat members.
And then you'd only see the ones that you needed to pay in that upcoming payment.
Rather than everything.
So you would still want to merge the two then wouldn't you?
Potentially no.
It's just more of like with the upcoming payments with like how I'm understanding it currently.
Those are expenses for the flat in its entirety.
Yes.
Which means that like anyone who's in the flat could just pick one and pay it and pay it now.
Because I feel like on like my home screen I'd want to see payments that are for me.
Not like because I might not be paying the food.
So like I don't really need to be seeing that because that's not my responsibility at the moment.
Whereas like I would want to see they're like, okay, I'm in charge of groceries this week.
There's my groceries payment.
And then I'd scroll down to pay up and I'd say, okay, they paid for the food this this week.
Let me chuck it across.
Okay.
Awesome.
All right.
Is there anything else they want to add?
I'd probably make this almost like a drop down.
Like instead of upcoming payments being the total, just have it so like each individual upcoming payment.
You can see like, oh, John's paid this for it.
Bob's paid this.
Oh, like the groceries.
Yeah.
You drop down from the groceries and it'll tell you who's paying it or who's paying it.
So each item in upcoming payments you would say John has paid this much.
Yeah.
I mean, regardless, it is quite a lot of like space just for like text that doesn't really sort of do anything in a way.
In the middle of space you mean?
Yeah.
Like on your home screen, I feel like it should have some extra sort of functionality in a way.
Okay.
I've got a sort of just like pain in the ass thing, but probably just make the dates a bit bigger.
The dates?
Oh yeah, that's fair.
I mean, to be fair, this is meant to be on a phone that's meant to be closer.
Obviously I'm showing it to you on my laptop, but like it is meant to be like in your face
a little bit more, but yeah, I can see that it's pretty small.
That's it for me.
I got nothing else.
Awesome.
No, no, awesome.
These are the kinds of things.
This is what I expect from you.
The more you give, the more I can cut away and leave the good parts.
Absolutely.
We're trying to give you some issues.
Be as nit-picky as you like.
The more issues you can solve, the better you're going to do on that part, right?
Exactly, yeah.
So anyone got anything else they want to mention?
No?
No other overall feedback?
Just like overall make summative information more accessible.
Well not accessible information, more of a main sort of...
Yeah, I feel like the app's pretty easy to use when you're like given the tasks that
you've got to do.
It's just when like, like here, we talk about the whole thing.
That sort of...
Yeah, it's when you open it up and you have to figure it out yourself.
Yeah, and you're sort of overthinking it in a way.
I wasn't confused when I was using it at the start, but then...
Awesome.
Yeah, when you start to think about it, it's like, wait a minute.
Yeah.
Alright, we've given you 20 minutes where we are going.
I think we should stop.
Yeah, that's probably good enough.
Awesome.
Thank you very much.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Bye.